zeitgleich sind Beamte heute Morgen wie
hier in Berlin angerückt um 15 Objekte
der klimaaktivisten der sogenannten
letzten Generation zu durchsuchen
hintergrund ist ein Ermittlungsverfahren
der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München
gegen mehrere Aktivistinnen und
Aktivisten im Alter von 22 bis 38 Jahren
Tatvorwurf ist hier der Anfangsverdacht
für die Mitgliedschaft bzw Unterstützung
einer kriminellen Vereinigung gegen
insgesamt 7 Beschuldigte seit rund einem
Jahr kleben sich klimaaktivisten der
letzten Generation bundesweit immer
wieder auf Straßenfest oder beschmieren
Fassaden mit Farbe wie hier gestern in
Berlin die SPD-Zentrale um auf ihre
Forderungen aufmerksam zu machen
offline heute die Webseite der letzten
Generation zudem hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft konnten der
Aktivisten gesperrt und Vermögenswerte
gesichert den beschuldigen wird konkret
unter anderem vorgeworfen eine
Spendenaktion organisiert beworben und
durchgesetzt zu haben um Geldern
einzuwerten
um quasi weitere Straftaten der letzten
Generation zu finanzieren nach dem
bisherigen Erkenntnissen hat man auf
diese Weise 1,4 Millionen Euro gesammelt
Reaktion der klimaaktivistinnen und
Aktivisten auf einer spontanen
Pressekonferenz
die 15 Hausdurchsuchungen die heute
morgen stattgefunden haben haben alle
Unterstützer der letzten Generation hart
getroffen sie machen uns Angst aber wir
dürfen nicht in dieser Angst verharren
die Bundesregierung fährt uns gerade
sehenden Auges in eine klima-hülle die
Regierung ignoriert wissenschaftliche
Fakten
sie verweigert das zu tun was notwendig
wäre um das Überschreiten der Kipppunkte
und damit den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenbruch zu verhindern trotz oder
gerade wegen der heutigen Razzien planen
die klimaaktivistinnen und Aktivisten
der letzten Generation heute und in den
nächsten Tagen in Berlin Leipzig und
München Großdemonstrationen und über die
Razzien in sieben Bundesländern sprechen
wir mit Rainer Band von der deutschen
Polizei Gewerkschaft zugeschaltet aus
Essen schönen guten Tag
hallo also eine großrazin sieben
Bundesländern sie haben die
Durchsuchungen bereits begrüßt warum ist
dieses Vorgehen ihrer Meinung nach
gerechtfertigt
zunächst einmal haben
Staatsanwaltschaften und Polizei einen
gesetzlichen Auftrag nämlich den
auftragsstraftaten zu verfolgen mit dazu
zählt auch die Sicherung von Beweisen
und wie in diesem Fall auch die
Sicherstellung von Vermögenswerten damit
folgten die Staatsanwaltschaft und die
Polizei ihrem gesetzlichen Auftrag daran
ist zunächst einmal nichts ungewöhnlich
aber ich kann mir natürlich vorstellen
dass viele Menschen genau darauf
gewartet haben dass der Staat nun
endlich auch konsequente Reaktionen
zeigt denn viele tausend Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die täglich stundenlang in ihren
Autos festgehalten werden die sind es
wirklich leid sie haben es gerade
angesprochen dass festgehalten werden in
ihren Autos also festkleben auf der
Straße das sind ja die Aktionen mit
denen die jetzige Generation in letzter
Zeit vor allem auf sich aufmerksam
gemacht hat das ist sicherlich für viele
in Ärgernis aber es ist natürlich
trotzdem die Frage ist das bereits eine
Straftat oder doch wie einige sagen eher
friedlicher ziviler Ungehorsam
und das ist ja keine Geschmacksfrage
sondern das ist eine Frage der
gerichtlichen Beurteilung
Gerichtsurteile werden ja nicht in
Talkshows oder sonstwo gesprochen
sondern vor Gericht und das ist ja schon
sehr häufig passiert endlich Gerichte
sind zu der Auffassung gelangt dass hier
Straftaten nämlich nötigungsstatbestände
vorliegen und haben entsprechende
Urteile gefällt gleichzeitig hat
beispielsweise das Landgericht Potsdam
auch den Anfangsverdacht der Bildung
einer kriminellen Vereinigung vorgesehen
und im Übrigen geht es nicht nur um das
Festkleben auf Straßen sondern bei im
Falle der Münchner Staatsanwaltschaft
auch noch um die Beeinträchtigung von
kritischen Infrastrukturen auf also auf
Attacken gegen eine Ölpipeline da sind
also schwerste Straftaten dahinter und
deshalb sind die Maßnahmen gerecht
werden fertigt
juristisch wahrscheinlich auch noch mal
aufgearbeitet und geklärt der
Bundesverkehrsminister der hat ja auch
mit den Aktivisten sich bereits
getroffen und einige Bürgermeister haben
auch Vereinbarung mit der letzten
Generation getroffen wie
sollte man aus ihrer Sicht aus der Sicht
der Polizei denn mit den Aktivisten am
sinnvollsten umgehen
am besten so wie es im Gesetz steht
nämlich einfach Straftaten verfolgen
aber dabei das richtige politische
Signal aufsetzen Kai Wegner der
Regierende Bürgermeister von Berlin hat
richtigerweise gesagt er spricht nicht
mit der letzten Generation weil man
nicht den Eindruck erwecken will dass
man nur Straftaten begehen muss um dann
möglichst dabei auf höchster politischer
Ebene Gesprächstermine zu bekommen das
ist das absolut falsche Signal
Straftäter werden in diesem Land
verurteilt und rechtmäßig behandelt aber
nicht aufgrund ihrer Straftaten auch
noch zum Gesprächstermin gebeten ein
völlig falsches Signal ich finde kein
Wegner in Berlin hat ausdrücklich recht
ob das alles Straftaten sind das müssen
Juristen erst noch klären das ist
sicherlich nicht in allen Fällen schon
geklärt also noch mal die Frage sonst
wie man mit diesen Aktion umgehen soll
braucht es denn auch aus ihrer Sicht
noch eine Verschärfung der Gesetze weil
der deutsche Richter Bund sagt ja bisher
nein
nein das braucht man nicht wir sehen ja
dass die Gerichte sehr abgestuft aber
dann auch konsequent urteilen zu
Verhinderung solcher Delikte gibt es den
sogenannten Unterbindungsgewahrsam der
soll in Berlin jetzt gerade verlängert
werden in anderen Ländern im Freistaat
Bayern beispielsweise gibt es hier zu 30
Tage auch davon wird Gebrauch gemacht
das ist aber die Gefahrenabwehr und
genau diese gesetzlichen Instrumente
muss man anwenden und zwar sehr
konsequent dann kann man rechtsstaatlich
geordnet mit diesem Phänomen umgehen
denn es gibt genügend Möglichkeiten
seinen Protest in Deutschland auf die
Straße zu bringen und zwar ohne die
Freiheit anderer Menschen tausendfach zu
beeinträchtigen sagt der Chef der
Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft Rainer
Wendt danke für Ihre Zeit